Auf dem mars passiert etwas ziemlich mysteriös
Nicht nur dass dort methan gefunden wurde ein gas das hier auf der erde vor allem durch tiere und pflanzen produziert wird das
absolut seltsame dabei es gibt
jahreszeitliche schwankungen und bisher konnte das phänomen
Geologisch einfach nicht geklärt werden gibt es also leben auf dem mars für und wider jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es kann sich wirklich niemand erklären als die ersten vorkommen von methan auf dem mars gemessen wurden da waren noch alle
Überzeugt dass es eine geologische erklärung
Geben müsse aber hier stoßen die wissenschaftler innen immer öfter an grenzen zitat das
ungewöhnlichste an dieser beobachtung sind die relativ großen schwankungen
Wir versuchen immer noch
Zu verstehen wie es zu diesen saisonalen schwankungen kommen dran so chris webber vom jet propulsion laboratory
jpl der nasa gegenüber dem wissenschaftsmagazin
Science bisher konnte noch keine stichhaltige erklärung aus der geologie gefunden werden
Im gegenteil immer mehr deutet auf eine biologische erklärung hin mit den bisherigen modellen konnten die großen schwankungen
einfach nicht erklärt werden der methangehalt ist zwar wahnsinnig gering steigt aber jahreszeitbedingt
um mehr als das doppelte von dem schnitt 0,3 auf bis zu
0,7 parts per million also 0,3 bis 0,7 millionen und das immer
Im spätsommer in der nähe des äquators eine biologische erklärung wäre wobei noch reine spekulation
zitat vielleicht wird das methan welchen quellen es auch immer entstand von irgendetwas
absorbiert vielleicht von poren, im oberflächen gestein so
Meteore wurden vermutet aber auch diese idee musste verworfen werden setzt massenhafte einschläge ließen den methangehalt
überhaupt nicht ansteigen nummer vom goddard space flight center der nasa
Zitat die andere erklärung über die kaum jemand spricht an die aber fast
Jeder denkt ist biologische aktivität auch vom leben erwarten wir schließlich eine gewisse
jahreszeitliche abhängigkeit
Also was ist da im boden was das gas produziert das hier auf der erde zum beispiel kühe beim rüsten ausstoßen oder
Bakterien die verfallen es ist wirklich ziemlich rätselhaft
Im april 2018 soll der trays gas orbiter
kurz tgo der europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa mit der erkundung der metallvorkommen beginnen dann erreicht
Er den geplanten orbit um den mars um mit der untersuchung zu starten es ist eines der haupt missionsziele des orbiters
Spurengase also trace gas also die geringen methan in der marsatmosphäre zu analysieren und die quellen zu finden
vielleicht wissen wir also schon bald mehr wenn er kein video dazu verpassen wollte und auch
Zu allen anderen themen durch mal hier ein aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn ansonsten kriegt ihr nicht mit wenn ein neues video online geht hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Sensationsfund auf dem mars theaters ist auch ziemlich spannend ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran